الشاب الجوكر وغيرها اسماء جديده بدانا
يعني نسمعها مؤخرا وصراحه الاخبار عنها
مرعبه هذه كلها اسماء انواع مخدرات بتغزوا
اسواق العالم وفيديوهات متداوله اونلاين
حقيقه نحن يعني مرعبه هذه الفيديوهات
لاشكال بني ادمين واقعين تحت تاثيرها
اليوم مثلا في هذا الفيديو المتداول
والقيل انه يوافذ فيه الكويت ولكن لسه
للان المعلومه مو مؤكده ولكن بغض النظر هو
فين او مين خلينا نشوفوا مع بعض عشان نفهم
لاي درجه مرعبه بالوضوء
[موسيقى]
هذا الفيديو متداول جديد اليوم لكن في
مثله كثير ومن كل دول العالم
[موسيقى]
ومؤخره شايفين تحركات عربيه لمكافحه هذه
الانواع من المخدرات الاردن عملات حمله
عليهم مصر كل شويه بتعلم ضبط عصابات مختصه
بالترويج والبيع السعوديه طبعا لسه من كم
يوم اعلنت احباط تهريب اكثر من 106 كيلو
من هذه الماده من منافذ حدوديه تحركات
يعني في كل مكان والاسئله صراحه كثيره
فمثلا ايش تفرق هذه المخدرات عن الانواع
الثانيه اللي معروفه من زمن وليه بيسموها
الزومبي خلونا نستفسر من ضيفتنا المختصه
اللي بتنضم الينا من جده دكتوره فاطمه
محمد كاكي استشاريه لطب نفسي وعلاج
الادمان اهلا فيك معنا دكتوره فاطمه اول
شيء خلينا نحاول نفهم منك ايش الفرق بينها
وبين المخدرات اللي اعتدنا السماع عنها
الكوكايين والهيروين وما الى ذلك
اشكرك واشكر القناه العربيه على الاستضافه
وعلى الموضوع الجميل وخاصه حمله السعوديه
وحمله العالم العربي ضد المخدرات او حرب
على المخدرات اولا خليني اتكلم عن الشبو
او الزومبي او الفلاكه هذا من المنشطات
بدا فيها عالم ياباني اسمه ناغه يوشي في
1893 اضاف على الانفيتامين عده مواد وطلع
ماده الكريستال او الشبوك جوفي الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
استخدمت المانيا النازيه على الجنود على
اساس تحسن جوده الجنود وكده كده هم
هيموتوا انهزموا ويموتوا يا انه ينتصروا
ويموتوا طب ايش هو الشبو يعني كثير ناس
يقول لك لا يا دكتور الشبو زي الهروين لا
الهيروين غير والشبو غير هو ماده منشطه
منبهه للجهاز العصبي المركزي يشتغل على
النواقل العصبيه وخاصه ماده الدوبامين
اللي هي بتشتغل على الحركه ولذه بالحياه
امازون فهد ماده الشبو بتشتغل على عالميا
حسب منظمه الصحه العالميه 2023 35 مليون
متعاطي الشبو في العالم
عكس زمان كان يعني لسه بالعشرينات 22 وشوي
شوي شوي صار 25 دحين صار 35 مليون عالميا
يتعاطى الشبو وفئه عمريه صغيره الشباب
اللي هم من 18 الى 25 اللي هم ثروه البلد
يعني اغلب
فيعني فهذا هو السبب كيف طب يفرقوا عن
المواد الثانيه
يشتغل على على المراكز الوظيفيه المعرفيه
على اساس كده بيؤدي الى انه هو بيحفز
الانسان ويؤدي الى سلوك عدواني فممكن يقتل
الوقت ايوه هذا هو يمكن هذه واحده من
الجزئيات اللي عليها كثير جدل انه
بيربطوها دائما على طول بالعنف
ومو اي عنف يعني نحن بنت كلم على انه شخص
يقتل
ايوه نعم صحيح لان هو يشتغل على الدوبامين
واشتغل على الفصه الجبهه اللي هو فيه
الوظائف المعرفيه طيب تساليني ايش هي
الوظائف المعرفيه الوظائف المعرفيه اللي
هي تميز الانسان عن اي كائن ثاني يعني حي
فالانسان ربي اكرمه بوظائف معرفيه التفكير
الدجاج من حسن التحكم يعني انا انا دكتور
فاطمه جالسه عشان انا اسمعكم وانتم
تسمعوني واكون واعي عن سلوكي تصرفاتي
وكلامي لكن اللي يتعاطى الشبو يفقد هذه
الميزه فيفقد فيصير عدائي فهو اكثر عداوته
على اهله فدحين القصص انه واحد قتل ابوه
المقعد قتل امه
فهذه الحوادث يعني كلها يقول لك طب ليش هل
ممكن احنا نعالجه في البيت انا امس بتحكي
لي وحده دكتوره انا قولي لي ايش الطريقه
وانا احبس واعاجي قلت لها لا يعني ممكن
الاضطرابات الزهانيه بالاضافه للجاج او
الوظائف المعرفيه مضروبه عنده
الهلاوس بتجي له اصوات امك تؤذيك ابوك
تاذيك اخوك
القصه انه كان عندنا مريض خرج من الطائف
ورجع البيت وهو انتكس بسرعه
فاعطوا له شابوا فريح على اخوه لانه اصوات
بتقول له اخوك يحبه ابوك اكثر منك وراح
سلخ راسه من من جسده ورماه على وجه ابوه
وهذه قصه حقيقيه سجلت قبل اربع سنين يعني
قتل اخوه بسبب انه الاصوات والاضرابات
اللي بتجيله شغاله فيه فهذا يعني صراحه
للامانه يعني هو ده سبب العنف والعدائيه
حقت
وبيقولوا كمان انه اسرع الادمان عليه اسرع
الوقوع فيه انه الواحد ممكن من اول مره
يدمن نعم ممكن وبالذات يعني اغلب الشباب
والشابات بيستخدموه وبيتستلزه لان هو يحفز
يعطيه طاقه يعطي نشاط يعطيه تركيز فكل
شويه بيزودوا الجرعه عشان يكونوا اكثر
نشاط ويسوي يعني بهجه
وفرك مود نفس اللي هي البهجه اللي في
الهيروين عشان كذا في ناس بيقول لك طب هو
زي الهي
لكن مع الاسف التجار اللي اشتغلوا على
الشبو لجوه رخيص وبتصنع من ماده الكبتاجون
او الانفيتامين عشان كذا الدوله حفظها
الله انه ضبطت كميات كبيره بحيث انها
تمنعها لان هم بدهم يجيبوا الان فيتامين
ويصنعوا منه الشبو لانه الشبو لوحده لازم
الماده الرئيسيه كثير ناس هو الماده
الاساسيه لتصنيع الشبو الانفتامين او
الكبتاجون بالمفهوم العام يضيفوا عليه
مواد حنذكرها يعني طيب وتحت الفكره ان
احنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كانت معنا
من جده دكتوره فاطمه محمد كاكي استشاريه
اولى طب النفسي وعلاج الادمان شكرا لك